this here is called a frog fish because
it looks like the front end guess it
comes in different species with their
own colors and shapes and it's very
patient even when it's hungry
despite is clown-like appearance it's a
voracious hunter he's stupid fish it's
strike is among the fastest in the
animal kingdom taking just one six
thousand of a second but now I read that
big guy it turns out the frog fish
doesn't really bite its prey by rapidly
expanding its ma to ten times its normal
volume the predator creates a vacuum
that sucks the victim in it's so
powerful Dyson should work on a new
vacuum the frogfish addition all that's
left to do is cut out some scales
the frogfish isn't just a master bird
force it's also pretty wily that reals
in global play by waving a spine that's
shaped like a worm
plus it's sneaky blending in perfectly
with its surroundings when it's on the
move it walks around on modified fins to
avoid kicking up sand I mean look at
that thing go
a frog fish maybe if you actually choose
your food you wouldn't walk like that